todos os segmentos mais um vídeo e hoje
vou ensinar como fazer o helicóptero de
cartão e para isso vão precisar de um
tempo aí como este aqui que é uma folha
de tamanho a3 por aí se vocês não
tiverem uma impressora que imprime a
folha desse tamanho não tem problema
nenhum de vocês podem baixar isto em
duas folhas tamanho a4 posição uma arma
e vão ter o mesmo tempo em que vocês vão
ver e que quando está bem é muito
difícil fazer se vocês quiserem poderá
internet ver uma imagem do copo e
desenhar vocês o próprio modelo seguindo
esta ideia do tempo do que isso e agora
é descansar tutorial goró com um tempo
você vai encontrar algumas linhas em
paralelo que indica a orientação do
cartão vocês podem ver neste pedaço aqui
é o dobro mais facilmente desta forma e
agora tentava dobrar na província de kwa
já não é tão fácil
então é muito importante que você siga a
orientação do cartão para as peças
ficarem mais resistentes
[Música]
em 11 jogos
prokop precisar de dois motores um para
a parte central pedirá elas grande um
pequenino para vocês colocarem legal é
utilizar um com caixa de munição na
parte central e um banho clínico 31
droga variado de cauda
agora é muito alto vocês não tenham os
mesmos motores que o treino que o que
você tem que fazer é adaptar de furos
para os vossos motores quem vai ficar
tudo os bairros
[Música]
o bom 1
por fazer ela exibe usar o tempo aí
porém se vocês quiserem podem utilizar
estes produtos que grandes para fazer
elas central e depois podem usar um
desolado corda com dimensão certa e
coloca na cauda do helicóptero
[Música]
e do copo já está feito agora para ficar
mais bonito e eu vou ensinar três armas
bastante simples porém vocês aqui podem
caprichar fazer o que vocês acham fica
melhor lançar rockets podem ensinar
aquela coisa para apagar os focos por
baixo
[Música]
a reprodução fiel do fim eu espero que
vocês tenham gostado desse projeto aqui
de um documentário que vocês acharam é e
sugestões do projeto também é muito
importante e fiquei contente porque esta
semana vai ter mais um projeto que é
isso não foi inscrito e inscreva se para
não perder nenhum vídeo que isso não
deveria ter sido até a próxima